reality warm purse real pieces of work
aren't they it's one thing when an
anomaly is all Claws and fangs like
scp-682 or if their attack of choice is
snapping necks like SCP-173 but it is an
entirely different story if an anomaly
can turn the air you breathe into
chocolate pudding or shove you into a
pocket Dimension that looks almost like
our own reality except everyone is just
a walking talking pile of spiders see
what I mean reality warpers real
handfuls though of course not all
reality warpers are created equal some
are relatively weak only affecting the
world around them in a mild ambient
fashion others can rattle whole
Dimensions with their tremendous power
the same also goes for Morality some
reality warpers are loving and
benevolent such as scp-343 the kindly
old all-powerful being known to some as
God and some are pure evil beings who
want nothing more than to use their
immense power to so chaos and misery
among everyone else and personally we
can't think of a better example of the
latter than Bill Cipher from Gravity
Falls this demonic Dorito wants nothing
more than to take over our Dimension and
rebuild it in His image of absolute
Insanity so naturally we started
wondering if these two reality warping
Titans
scp-343 and Bill Cipher ever came to
blows who would win we were so curious
in fact that we fired up the animatron
6000 our state-of-the-art simulation
supercomputer to see how exactly the two
might meet and how their epic battle
would play out who do you think would
take the coveted W on this one let us
know down in the comments along with any
other out of universe what-if situations
you'd love to see but in the meantime
let's fire up the machine be warned
folks it's gonna get weird the date was
July 12 2013. for scp-343 it had started
out as a relatively normal day he'd
spent the night playing Solitaire on the
astral plane before warping back into
his humanoid containment cell by morning
leaving the foundation on the wiser
after all he was really here voluntarily
if the foundation had truly wanted to
try to confine him here they were
welcome to give it a go but it would be
about as effective as trying to catch a
whisper in a butterfly net while God had
come to this place to experience the
joyful illusion of giving up control it
truly was little more than an allusion
to him if he wanted to he could
exterminate the SCP Foundation in less
than an afternoon then retire to Burger
King for a Whopper so really they're all
just lucky he is a benevolent being more
interested in hanging out than
dispensing wrath on those he perceived
as insolent that was Old Testament him
he'd done a lot of soul-searching and
growth since then it'd been at least a
millennium since he'd smote anyone for
that matter and the last guy really had
it coming however today today was going
to be a little different God knew that
something was going to happen today he
sensed a great source of energy emerging
something dark and malevolent he sighed
and he closed his eyes for a moment
focusing himself he knew whatever the
nature of this threat it would fall upon
him to face and destroy it how
irritating he was hoping to finally
binge stranger things today elsewhere
inside 19 things seemed to be
inordinately peaceful there hadn't been
any containment breaches or new
anomalies brought in there hadn't been
any attacks from rival groups of
Interest Dr bright hadn't even done
anything stupid or started any fires to
borrow an old cliche it was quiet too
quiet perhaps the only person who wasn't
having a relatively mellow day was
security officer Frederick Simmons a
mid-level guard who'd been stationed at
site 19 for four years now he just
wasn't really feeling himself today the
work didn't bother Simmons emotionally
at least
typically even after seeing rather
traumatic things or being in near-death
situations while in containment breaches
it hadn't left any lingering effects but
lately he'd been having the strangest
streams it always played out the same
way shortly after going to sleep he'd
open his eyes in a strange multi-colored
void surrounded by bizarre seemingly
random floating objects none of which
seemed to have any real relevance to him
or his life and just when he'd begin to
question it the other recurring element
of the dream would occur out of the
shimmering oil slick rainbow of
mind-boggling colors a strange being
would suddenly emerge a glowing Golden
Triangle almost like a drawing of a
pyramid the Eye of Providence with a
stove pipe hat a little bow tie thin
black arms and legs and most notable of
all a single large eye with a slit pupil
staring out from the center the eye
almost seemed to have a strange hypnotic
quality to it Sim felt Bewitched
whenever he looked into it he wasn't
afraid quite the opposite actually for
reasons he couldn't understand this
strange creature from the world of
Dreams seemed like a good friend of his
he said well well well well well well if
it isn't my number one guy the Fred
Meister in the house I've missed you
have you miss me put her there good
buddy The Entity extended his hand and
Simmons shook it the foundation guard
could feel a strange tingling sensation
jolting down his arm the first time
Simmons had encountered The Entity he'd
told him his name Bill Cipher and he
told him how incredibly important it was
that Simmons kept their little nighttime
meetings a secret in Exchange bill was
here to listen Simmons would spend his
time in the mindscape pouring out his
worries and frustrations with his daily
work as bill paid impeccable attention
the strange Little Dream entities seemed
fascinated by the work Sim instead all
the peculiar and wondrous anomalies he
guarded at site 19. but to Simmons it
was all just boring work zombie creating
Supernatural plague doctors and Immortal
men with metal limbs lose their shine
after you see them day in day out for
years on end frankly Simmons needed a
day off but he'd already used up all his
PTO when he'd gotten the flu earlier
that year he just didn't know what to do
luckily for him Bill had a solution bill
as it turned out had a fancy little
ability he could occupy the body of a
human being and operate it for them bill
could take the wheel while Simmons took
a load off in the mindscape how hard
could standing around pretending to look
busy at the SCP Foundation really be as
Bill explained the offer to him Simmons
couldn't really see any flaws in his
reasoning after all bill was a friend
why would he have any ill will towards
him with that he shook hands with the
bizarre Supernatural triangle and felt
the sudden rough sensation of having his
Consciousness ripped from his body only
for Bill to Slither in and take his
place the new Simmons the bill occupied
Simmons opened up his demonic yellow
eyes and grinned he gave a demented
laugh to Simmons floated disembodied
Soul
oh man he said wiping away a tear of
laughter with Simmons finger with your
body I
Ka Multiverse see ya sucker and with one
last demented chuckle Bill left for work
at the SCP Foundation with Simmons being
the latest in his long line of Meat
Puppets after arriving at site 19 he
sneaked through the facility knowing
exactly where he needed to be you see
Bill is a native entity of the second
dimension the world of flat shapes but
he's able to access the minds of beings
in the third dimension like us through
the medium of the mindscape rather than
the Physical Realm Bill's life goal has
always been to find a way to permeate
and take over the third dimension
turning it into his personal playground
all he needed was the right anomaly to
bring him forth into our world in this
case a little anomalous device favored
by Dr Kane pathos Crow
scp-158 also known as the soul extractor
while Dr Crow Left To the courtyard for
his evening walkies the being that most
people assumed was Fred Simmons secreted
himself into scp-158's containment
chamber and locked the door behind him
he didn't have much time he'd need to do
this perfectly if he wanted a real
chance at taking over the universe he
was amused by the irony at the least the
fact that in order to take over he
needed to sneak into the midst of the
people most likely to destroy him still
where's the fun in life with no risk at
scp-158's control console he inputted
the data to Soul extraction and set a
timer however there was one difference
between this and the usual procedures
performed with the soul extractor there
was no containment receptacle on the
other end whatever was extracted would
just be released into the world and this
was exactly what bill was counting on he
laid Simmons body down on the gurney and
watched with Glee as the robotic arm
lowered towards him it reached into his
chest and pulled out the essence of one
three-sided threat to reality Bill
Cipher one quick Journey Through the
bowels of the machine later the
nightmare scenario had come to pass Bill
floated around the room dragged into
physical reality he let out a long
conceited cackle and spun his Cane
around this was going to be fun
Elsewhere on the facility alarms were
going off and guards were deploying
nobody was meant to be in containment
chamber 158 so how was the soul
extractor currently operating this
couldn't possibly end well bill on the
other end was having a wonderful time it
was pondering all the different ways he
could make the draft clinical corridors
of the SCP Foundation into his vision of
perfect weirdness maybe he turned all
the researchers into mice and turned
site 19 into a giant maze to run them
through maybe he'd turn the air into
farts and release winged beasts from the
hell Dimension to ravage Humanity maybe
he'd go out into the parking lot and key
everyone's cars oh the Diabolical
possibilities were endless as he said
loaded out into the Hall his fantasizing
was interrupted by a group of foundation
security operatives wielding assault
rifles they entered an attack formation
and trained their rifles on him before
opening fire bill just found himself
laughing again the gunfire just tickled
wow you guys are hilarious Bill said
between fits of laughter but wait I
could think of a better way to make you
even funnier he snapped his fingers and
suddenly the guards were transformed
instead of the serious first line of
defense for the SCP Foundation they were
now a gang of literal clowns straight
from the circus holding balloon animals
molded into the shapes of assault rifles
they giggled and threw pies at each
other bill was right this did make them
even funnier and he was just getting
started turning this Foundation snooze
Fest into a party of cosmic proportions
Bill began running a rampage of
weirdness across the site essentially
being the ultimate Cosmic troll he
decided he'd simply bother every single
anomaly he could with his demonic Antics
first he appeared in scp-096's chamber
and pulled a brown paper bag over his
head with the words ugliness lies within
written on the front and just for fun he
then teleported the temperamental Beast
to a nearby Amish community it quickly
became enraged when a gust of wind blew
the bag off its head and a man named
Jebediah saw its face it then killed
several others also named Jebediah
during the Rampage Bill thought it was
hilarious he then released scp-682 into
site 19 and just to annoy the creature
into further violence he stuck an
indestructible party hat on the
monster's head no matter how hard 682
tried it couldn't remove the party hat
this caused it great frustration which
it took out on any foundation staff it
happened to find in the area it had
fulfilled Bill's expectations
wonderfully but his quest for amusing
Carnage didn't end there next he went to
bother
p049 the plague doctor who was in the
process of doing surgery on a foundation
provided Dead Goat with a snap of his
fingers Bill transformed the plague
doctor's surgical tools into colorful
Play-Doh cutting tools needless to say
the supernatural surgeon was less than
pleased he was about as annoyed as Dr
clef was when bill turned his favorite
shotgun into a bouquet of flowers then
sealed his feet into the floor or how
Vex Dr gears was when bill turned his
plain beige necktie into a considerably
more loud and colorful tie people there
at the time reported hearing Dr gear say
I just don't think that was necessary oh
and he also did some more minor acts of
malice he filled the break room with an
army of flesh-eating zombies he made a
mode filled with molten lava around the
site that prevented anyone from escaping
from his reign of terror and he even
covered all the walls in cognito
hazardous Doodles that instantly drove
any weak-minded human who saw them into
complete gibbering Madness it was clear
this reality warping nightmare needed to
be stopped before he got bored of
playing with his new Foundation toys and
decided to go remodel the universe in
his own image thankfully there was one
anomaly on site who was up to the task
bill was treating himself to another
evil laugh in the site-19 canteen when
something peculiar happened he looked
down to see a man in what looked like a
tunic with graying hair and a beard he
walked with a peculiar kind of calmness
his face blank why wasn't the sky
panicking was he stupid bill would
seemingly need to teach this guy a thing
or two about fear hey Grant don't know
if it's escaped your attention but I've
been giving this place an Extreme
Makeover did you forget to put on your
glasses this morning or are you just
that senile The Stranger remained calm
as could be it replied with a voice that
was measured as it was deep now Bill
let's not resort to name-calling that's
just childish don't you think Bill's
single eye widened at this wait wait
hold up how did you know my name Bill
asked irritated are you a friend of the
time baby or something he floated over
and began circling the stranger hoping
to intimidate him much to Bill's
frustration it didn't appear to be
working I know lots of things Bill lots
of things The Stranger replied that's my
line Bill screeched turning red who Do
You Think You Are The Stranger gave a
quiet Reserve chuckle that infuriated
Bill oh personally I just like to think
of myself as a humble Craftsman watching
his beautiful creation play out he said
what are oppose some of the people
around here like to call me God
Bill didn't like this this whole
universe was going to be his and he
certainly didn't appreciate some insulin
old man acting like he ran the roost
around here bill would give him an
education in who was really holding the
Reigns and it would be the kind of
education that left scars if it left
anything at all he extended his spindly
black arms and released bolts of
lightning against the stranger who
simply continued to smile as the
electricity rippled around him seemingly
causing no effect are you done the
stranger asked Bill laughed hoping to
hide his irritation I'm just getting
started he bow out with a thunderous
Roar that shook the very foundations of
sight 19. Bill began to grow and shift
no longer a silly little triangle he
became a huge Red Pyramid of pure
nightmares covered in glowing Golden
Arms and teeth with long black tongues
drooping out of each level it was the
most terrifying and demonic form in his
entire Arsenal and yet he was astonished
to find that the stranger still didn't
seem to show any kind of fear very
impressive Bill The Stranger said
sounding almost bored but I think you
might be trying a little too hard oh
that does it bill would simply have to
destroy him it was a matter of Pride now
he raised several of his huge golden
fists and began pounding down on the
comparatively tiny humanoid stranger it
was an assault so powerful that the
ground began cracking around their feet
and yet it seemed that with almost no
effort The Stranger was able to
intercept and block every single blow
naturally bill was infuriated it was
time to finally unleash the full breadth
of his power on this beardy wise guy he
launched Thunderbolts Fireballs Legions
of giant mutant wasps hailstorms
maelstroms bubbles of pure Madness
snakes made out of barbed wire and even
incredible coarse language but despite
it all this man the one who claimed
people called him God was utterly
unfazed you can dish it out he said but
let's see if you can take it Bill began
to laugh what the heck's that supposed
to mean you can't God snapped his
fingers and Bill was gone vanished and
with a flick of his wrist all the damage
and Transformations that Bill had
performed had disappeared it was as
though the Demonic triangle had never
even been there in the first place
though Dr bright who was acting site
director at the time had some Scranton
reality anchors turned on around the
perimeter just to be safe you can never
be too careful with reality warping
demons after all later that day Dr
bright approached God and asked him what
he'd actually done with Bill God chuckle
then replied for a being of such immense
power he really had a rather childish
mindset so I sealed him away inside a
children's cartoon where he couldn't do
any further damage what was the cartoon
Dr bright asked a Charming little Disney
show called Gravity Falls God replied
now go check out your questions for God
answered and scp-096 versus scp-343 for
more of this singularly Unique Reality
warper